After I left I think David--David is the mysterious person who is not here.
He wrote the MapReduce system by hand. Is that correct? >>Yes. >>And you guys are now replacing that with--?
>>We're switching over to Hadoop using a language called Pig or Pig Latin.
Hadoop is a MapReduce system, and it has the advantage of handling all the details
of distributing these mappers and reducers across a cluster of nodes, and we're actually
using Amazon's elastic MapReduce, which has hosted Hadoop to make our lives simpler.
So one of the cool things about Amazon--we talked previously in this lecture
about AWS--the Amazon Web Services.
As Amazon has built-in not just machines but this whole Hadoop clusters
that you can commission and pay for.
So you guys are moving to that direction and use those at Hipmunk now too for our log analysis.
It's really cool, because you can just basically put in queries and say here's my data--
we actually store our data in S3 in these big text files, and we just say run this query
using 20 machines over all this data and you can basically say,
how long do I want to wait. and Amazon will bring up all the machines,
load your data in, run the job, output it, and then shut all the machines down.
Yeah. It's pretty great. >>So you guys are going to be running MapReduce constantly though. >>Right right.
Like every 15 minutes or something? >>Yeah.
That's an interesting question of how to do that with EMR. I mean, you can do it.
You just need to say that right.
Okay, so you're still kind of figuring out how that's--. >>Yeah.
And that's going to compute the hot pages for every Reddit?
It's mostly user pages but there are are few other things.
It's stuff like your top links of this hour--that kind of stuff. >>Okay. Okay.